für unser nächsten tag habe ich direkt
zahlreiche gäste eingeladen ich sage nur
dieter bohlen jürgen klopp franz
beckenbauer jürgen
klinsmann alles in einer person nämlich
matze knop kommt zu clixoom
das ist der mann der dauergast in waldis
em club war der auf bild.de immer wieder
in die ein oder andere rolle schlüpft
und diese promis oft auch kennengelernt
hat er hat also eine menge zu erzählen
und freut sich auf eure fragen in den
kommentaren und auch als video fragen
die ja mit einem klick in die
kommentarbox dann taucht dann eben das
feld zum upload einer video antwort
hochladen könnt also haut rein er ist
gespannt ich bin gespannt und bis dann
bleibt an